how are you this is god I've never been
here before so I'm gonna join the first
time they had a movie I'm here right you
all still look at you you know blazing
finder out front out front
Vanguard by the way who is here with me
today is this 23 year old will or 1 year
old will no 51 year old will is always
here I'm just noticing my posture right
now you know
51 year old will is all the way here
just like my feet hurting my back hurt
yeah that's cuz you were on stage and
Budapest celebrating your birthday doing
this little moon there that's how you
gonna see that's it you got to be real
confident to do that when you're not
about pow and then you just give it to
him like you know you know what I'm
talking about you know what it is do the
kids appreciate dads groove no not at
all so Trey there's like you know what
let Dad be dad we're gonna let him do
him and Jaden just kind of keeps it
quiet and he just looks and watches and
we'll always like ah dad really
seriously that's too much and that's too
much okay our friends are watching that
you are well your friends will be
watching this movie too
what is it like when you see a 23 year
old you played back on the screen
for the first time yeah that was crazy
it was like you know cuz we had to shoot
all of this stuff ahead of time and it
was eight months before I got to see an
image and it is really it it's weird
when you see yourself talking to
yourself there it was the first time I
saw it in the first saw first shot I saw
as well one of the best shots in the
movie it's the one where the old will
flip the young will and then puts the
flashlight on his face and it's the
first time we see them and it's just one
one of those shots that it's exquisitely
done because you know it's a hundred
percent digital character and that's the
thing that that I keep repeating to
people people it's not me
da okay it's a 100% digital character
they can they created that character
totally in the computer right so it's a
essentially a digital avatar that I put
the things on and I'm working an avatar
right right so it was the the process of
it was a difficult process because you
can't really you don't really see
anything but when I first saw it blown
away they have to create that 23-year
old you but you still have to play that
character so what do you tap into when
you got to play a 23 year old yeah it's
really you know what was great as I had
so much filmography so aang meant and
grabbed six degrees of separation he
grabbed bad boys and Independence Day so
the the the team at Wetty was working
off of the essentially the look of the
bad boys and six degrees of separation
age range so they were creating around
those images but you can't you can't
fake innocence that was the thing that
was really hard it's a whole lot easier
to play older than it is to play younger
it's like there's certain things once
you know them it's hard to get them get
them out of there at night you know
there's certain knowledge that just
takes root in yourselves you know that
it's hard to it's hard to get out of
there but it was it was you know fun to
watch all of my old stuff it was a
little bit a little bit of that and also
to see just the quality of insanity I
was living in in in that age like like
not knowing is actually a superpower if
it doesn't kill you like it like not
knowing what you can do and you didn't
know anything it's that naivete is such
a power cuz you'll try anything there's
a line in the film where you the more
younger will says I am the best and
older wills like you're obviously not
really not the best what would you tell
younger will but will in his 20s right
now
to kind of prepare him for where you are
today well first of all will in his 20s
wasn't listening to nothing and nobody
had to say
so that that's first and more first of
course I wouldn't tell his dumb ass
nothing but there were there were
certain qualities that I had in my
twenties that I've been trying to
recover in the last couple of years yeah
so you know my birthday last year I went
a I did bungee jumping out of a
helicopter over the Grand Canyon and
even a part of that foolishness was
trying to get rid of the the fear that I
had taken on as I became more successful
I didn't I didn't become more brave like
I became more fearful as I got older
right so young will was wildly
courageous like he would go to the
courageous courageous to the level of
foolishness but I would want to ask my
younger self about the source of that
courage because I've actually lost touch
with that with that source I have to
manipulate it a little more now than I
used to my most favorite thing in the
world is when J that calls you Willard
you're about to get another birthday
gift this year Tyler Perry is dedicated
to you and his New Atlantis to do how do
you feel about that I think that that is
fantastic
I love how Tyler is thinking about our
people young man to ever own a studio
outright it's like you know I just I
just want to support what he's doing
there you know there's a part that is
excited about it for me and for my
legacy and for my family but more than
anything I am excited for the the place
that he's creating for alternate stories
you know so I just I'm I'm gonna go down
there and for me more than for myself
I'm going down to pat him on his back
tell him good job that's legacy for you
to know listen I want to play a little
game in honor of Jim and I man right
okay this is Bri we're gonna call this
older younger costo so you have to guess
who this person is that you're looking
at right now whoa
Oh the only person I've worked with with
those eyes is Margot that's fantastic
that's fantastic yeah ha wait so hold on
so it does that looks at this Jada or
gam in there somewhere right yeah
younger damn yeah yeah that's fantastic
this is these are really good that is
crazy I cannot this is a good one let me
help you
yeah that's Milo Ventimiglia who said he
got his start on Fresh Prince that's I
recognize that cuz it is close that's
Jaden that's that is that's good that's
good whoever did those though that
Gemini Gemini stuff is that's great I
mean the man the myth the legend yes
three-time Academy Award winner Angley
and get me better than this
I love the fact that you two teamed up I
know you've been trying to get this made
forever but you were saying the
technology just wasn't there
it wasn't me for 20 years from Studio to
studio I was in touch like two two and a
half years ago I was pitched the idea
everybody has a feeling that the
technologies within rich not that we can
do it but feels like maybe we can do it
so we all jump in and of course there's
only maybe three two guys can do this
it's interesting because I've seen this
kind of concept you know a lot in the
last samuel l.jackson did it in Captain
Marvel the men and the Irishmen are
playing younger versions of themselves
and now we have will doing that are we
now going to be able to actually write
87 years because we can just like create
younger versions of ourselves and do
different things for me the art of there
could be a younger Will Smith younger
Marlon Brando movie oh right like it
really with this technology and and
that's the part it's so I'm telling cuz
it's so hard for people to understand
it's not a younger will it's a
completely digital character right so
it's a digital character that performed
by me that that could be propeller like
by it looks like me but it could be
performed by another actor another actor
could work the avatar because now it's a
digital character that will exist when
I'm gone yeah but nobody does that here
and in quivery jaw can you expand just a
little bit on why this is not be aging
cuz I think all of us in our head thing
even though I hear you say it I'm still
like yeah but it's younger will well if
the aging is you D your age no what we
did is we create a young Will Smith
that's a difference not from there not
of this guy except the heart of this guy
Oh what he wished to be so it's like in
Life of Pi when you see the tiger right
so there was never actually a real tiger
there right so it was it's a it is they
looked at Tigers they use Tigers they
film Tigers to get the movement and all
of that but there was never actually a
tiger there that's how this character is
it's a full digital character and there
was never actually a Will Smith there in
that that's the idea right so it's
completely not reducing a new character
yeah are we changing the way we're
reviewing cinema now I mean is this
movie really kind of changing the way we
consume cinema I hope it's a beginning
because we're in a digital era there's a
full of other sort of possibilities
instead of physically pretending
something to tell a story that they just
haven't helped us go all kinds of places
I think it's a very valuable tool that
isn't still new to us relatively new to
us I think there's a lot of potentials
but so right now it's very difficult as
a lot more expensive than Will Smith I'm
being honest I am technologically inept
I still have an iPhone 6 is bad oh yeah
you might have to pop up but your
technology game is on point especially
with social media like you really tap in
and you really use it yeah about I've
always loved technology my my father was
an engineer right so he was an
electrical engineer so it's like math
and science was huge in my house so I've
always loved technology and now with
social media that being able to connect
to people around the world I get to get
to feed that joy moment-to-moment
yeah can willow really check you is she
the only one that can really check you
you know I mean it's like I mean that's
my baby girl you know she gets leeway
that the others don't necessarily get I
got so much and and finally I did want
to ask about bel-air athletics because
that just that just dropped I love it I
need those fresh you know I love doing
that you know merch and stuff like that
because I never did it before it was a
you know that's a part of the New Age
now to how you can interact as as a
movie star in the past you had to be as
mysterious and as separate from the fans
as we love about y'all though cuz you
don't play that
y'all really don't play but we're you
know out there in a in a different way
now you can get away with a lot more
contact with a it's almost like creating
a daily relationship and a friendship
than it is trying to sustain
mythological imagery of yourself you
know you almost broke the internet with
that Neopost that you did yeah you got
everybody calling for you to be in the
new one with Jade with with Jada and
Keanu can you could it be yeah I'm doing
whatever movie Angley wants me to do so
whatever whatever Angley brings up next
and I whisper in your ear Eng I got to
my
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]